Peter Schweitzer the author of secret
empires have the American political
class hides corruption and enriches
family and friends boy that couldn't be
a more germane title and he joins us
tonight Peter thanks so much for coming
on we also have sent you a couple of
emails that this show obtained
exclusively that appear to shed some
light on what hunter Biden was doing for
the Ukrainians what does it add up to do
you think well I think it adds up to is
the Biden family cashing in through by
corruption by proxy hunter sorry Joe
Biden is Vice President or his wife Jill
Biden can't take payments from foreign
entities that would have to be disclosed
that would be easy to catch but you set
up your adult kids and in the case of
the Biden's Joe Biden was point person
for the Obama administration towards two
countries China and Ukraine and lo and
behold the two countries that hunter
Biden ends up doing the most business in
overseas are China and Ukraine and the
amounts of money are astronomical and
the deals that he got have absolutely
nothing to do with his background he had
no expertise to sell
he had no skillset to sell to either the
Chinese or Ukrainians he was being paid
for something Tucker
it certainly wasn't his skillset I think
we know what he was being paid for I you
know I watched over the weekend I don't
watch a lot of TV typically in the
weekends but there's an impeachment
afoot it seemed like it was worth
checking it and I saw a news anchor
after news anchor on all the channels
back down suggestions that there was
anything wrong with hunter Biden's
arrangement with Ukraine why would they
why would they say that do you think
well I think the rules are different for
certain people
look does anybody really believe that
those news anchors if we were talking
about Donald Trump and Donald Trump jr.
going to Ukraine and Don junior getting
by the way hundred Biden was being paid
eighty-three thousand dollars a month we
know that because we have the bank
records the Morgan Stanley account that
it went into his business partner ended
up in a criminal trial and we got those
banking records but does anybody
seriously think if the name was Trump
instead of Biden that the news anchors
on Sunday morning would have the same
attitude it's ridiculous everybody knows
the answer to that and I think Tucker
this is what frustration
more than anything yeah yeah a flush
that's people more than anything well I
you know look people I think a lot of
people like Trump or don't like Trump
like the Democrats don't like the
Democrats but at the end of the day they
still want to believe firmly that we are
a nation of laws not of men but it
depends what your last name is it
depends what your political affiliation
is you know think about what did we hear
in 2017 after the 2016 election
everybody said you can't investigate
Hillary Clinton she's not running for
anything anymore she's not going to be
in office
you can't investigate her what are they
saying now Joe Biden is running for
office so you can't investigate him
either the question becomes when do you
get to investigate anybody at the
highest level for criminal conduct and
the answer apparently at least from one
side of the aisle is you never get to
investigate our people ever yeah well
let's just let's just make it really
easy for the traveling press krause put
that picture back up on the screen
here's Joe Biden his son his son's
business partner the two of the four
guys in that picture we're working for
the Ukrainians did they talk about it on
the golf course I mean there it is right
there someone ought to ask Joe Biden
yeah it's not it's not complicated yeah
look we know that Joe Biden lied when he
said that and we know that because first
of all his own son hunter Biden told The
New Yorker that he did talk to his
father about the verismo deal we also
know that Devin Archer in that picture
had a meeting in the White House
one-on-one meeting with Joe Biden about
a week before they joined the burries
mabh ORD and finally we know as it
relates to the China deal that the
Chinese officials the Chinese business
partners a hunter Biden admitted that
when they took that trip to Beijing
China hunter introduced them to his
father while he was father was on that
official trip so he's just lying when he
said they didn't discuss business
there's too much evidence otherwise yeah
and that's the offensive part Ukraine is
not a threat to us China is a threat to
us Peter Schweitzer thanks so much for
that for those details good to see you
mate thanks doctor